costumes d'aliénor que je suis en train
de mettre la pure et à mesure c'est bien
ça ensuite oui c'est le costume de lady
marianne dans robin des bois à l'envers
le film robin des bois de ridley scott
qui est sorti je sais pas vers 2010
quelque chose comme ça est bon
historiquement il n'était pas terrible
armure ajusté de lézinnes rihanna la fin
est un petit que what the fuck
mais j'avais bien aimé certains costumes
déjà j'ai bien aimé le film en lui-même
les musiques étaient géniales costumés
galère très galère avec pascal trois
couches c'est chiant et à enlever
je suis obligé de pour m'en vais jongler
me consortiaux nick pas possible enfin
la base j'avais fait ce costume pas ce
que je fais du cosplay aussi du jeu nous
dire sur twitter ou quelque chose comme
ça donc c'est la reproduction de
costumes tirés de fiction
on a beaucoup qui font avec des costumes
de manga et moi c'est plutôt avec des
costumes de films de trois couches et
donc le costume de les îles mariannes
c'est un costume qui n'est même pas
d'époque en fait parce que gym est censé
se passer
12e celle d'une assemblée ça on m'a dit
que c'était un dossier plutôt casier
balle allait la voir mais jamais fait
parce que je trouvais jolie cossu qui a
fait quant à lui qu'elle porte quand
elle laboure les champs rien de glamour
et l'autre costume un peu rose que je
portais cet été et plus léger c'est le
costume de azénor l'une des maîtresses
du roi arthur dans kaamelott que j'avais
fait un groupe camelot pour une
vingtaine expo qui était super marrant
et donc moi j'avais fait une des
maîtresses du roi arthur parce que tous
les personnages cool était déjà pris
donc moi j'ai fait et la maîtresse
cleptomane qu'on ne voit que dans un
épisode mais c'est pas grave c'était
marrant on a vu plein de prix en plus
c'était bien éclaté avec la prestation
est clos vont quitter en affaires
perceval un truc voilà bah on va tourner
la suite maintenant a fait et ça ne va
pas se faire tout seul voilà c'était le
petit aparté